[Music]
presumably you can hear this there's
some construction happening in the house
next door and for the last hour or maybe
two hours or so it seems like this is
the ground smashing portion of whatever
construction they're doing and just the
whole house has been shaking which you
will be able to hear if they continue I
think it's still going on now so if
you're curious that's what the sound is
now in one of the intro questions that
you were just answering you are actually
going to have your mind primed to think
about what we're going to talk about
today this question just made me laugh
so much to write it and try to think it
through it's asking if X is the number
that most people are going to enter into
this box what is 2 to the X going to be
and it's just so mind confiding because
you think about okay if a lot of people
are entering one I should enter two but
everyone would think about that so maybe
I should enter four but everyone thinks
about that so I should do 2 to the 4 or
maybe 2 to that or maybe 2 to leave that
and you know if it was a roomful of
perfect logicians you'd blow up to
infinity but people aren't logicians and
there is some objectively correct answer
and we can take a look at what the
objectively correct answer is in this
context and it would appear most ok the
largest number of people entered to
which means anyone who entered 4 is
absolutely correct but in the game where
you imagine thinking through you know
the perfect logicians and you're taking
two to the two to the two to the two
you're starting to think about the topic
for today's video which is an operation
that's not typically taught in school
probably because it doesn't have the
same level of applications as certain
other ones but as you'll see there's a
couple puzzles that we can start to do
with it that absolutely bring out some
very important problem-solving skills
and ideas of just really thinking
through what terms actually mean and
whether or not operations that you're
doing it seemed to make sense when you
do it symbolically actually makes sense
when you think through what's really
going on so this operation is called
tetration and a way you might think
about it is you know we all learn about
addition is one of the first things the
way that we can add two numbers and
multiplication as we first see it is
repeated addition a times B is a
say plus a plus a B different times and
if you say well what happens if we
repeat multiplication you know taking a
times a times a times a B different
times we write it as a to the power B
and that's exponentiation now if you
were to go one step further in this
process and say what happens if we
repeat exponentiation this has a name we
call it tetration tetra comes from the
greek for for because it's sort of the
fourth stage in this process of
repeatedly applying the previous
operation and of course in the context
of things like multiplication we've
extended the idea beyond just counting
numbers so here this only makes sense if
B was a counting number but we do things
like taking pi times E or even complex
values where you can take the square
root of 2 times 1 plus I so we've
extended it beyond repeated addition but
that's sort of its origin that's the way
that we often start thinking about it
similarly very famously one thing we've
been talking affair about in this series
is extending exponentiation with the
classic euler's formula example but for
right now we're just going to think of
this tetration in terms of repeating an
integer number of times d here i I swear
this is we were we were so dreading the
idea that the ground smashing day would
come during one of the streams but here
we are now this is actually ambiguous if
we don't define our terms a little bit
more clearly because exponentiation is
not associative meaning the order that
we do these operations and start
collapsing it matters because if I was
going from left to right let's say I was
writing this as 2 squared and then I'm
going to think of squaring that and then
squaring the result that will get me a
different number then I think if I think
of going from the top to the bottom if
the first thing I evaluate is the 2 to
the power 2 at the top and then I go to
the next one and we can think about why
here if I'm collapsing from the bottom
that bottom part is 4 so then I square
it and I'll square that 4 squared is 16
so I square that and I ended up getting
256 but on the bottom if I start by
collapsing that top term it becomes a 4
and then if I think of collapsing the
current top term that becomes 2 to the
16 and that's a much bigger number that
is 65,536 and in general this process of
repeatedly exponentiating going from the
top to the bottom explodes very quickly
and tetration in general refers to the
top to the bottom part so we start
evaluating at a top and we work down if
you want to make that crystal clear I
think instead of drawing it as a power
tower one thing that you could do is
define the iterative process very
exactly you might say we have some value
that we're going to start out at one and
then each successive value is going to
be 2 to the power of the previous thing
so a sub 1 would just be 2 a sub 2 is
going to be 2 to the power of whatever a
sub 1 was which in this case is 2
squared a sub 3 is going to be 2 to the
power of whatever a sub 2 was which now
is 2 to the 2 to the 2 and there's no
more ambiguity for what the order of
operation should be because you see that
it came from the a 2 terms so we should
first be evaluating what's in the top
and similarly if you go on like this and
a sub n for any value n is equal to 2 to
the previous term a sub n minus 1 when
you unfold this expression and kind of
go back in our recursive definition what
you're going to get is a power tower of
2 and different times now another thing
that's nice about writing it like this
is we can become experimental and as you
all know I love to encourage people to
be very playful when you come across a
new operation like this and a lot in
this series we've just been pulling up
some Python to do that so let's do that
here let's take this iterative process
and see what it actually looks like so I
will go over to my terminal I will open
up some Python I will set an initial
value of a to be 1 and then what I want
to do is take a look at 2 to the power
of that but I'm going to reassign that
value into a so this double asterisk
that's how we take powers in Python and
then in a lot of programming languages a
single equal sign it's not a question
it's not asking if they're equal it's an
operation it's saying take whatever is
sitting
on that right side and shove it into the
left value okay so when we do this it
reassigns the value of a2 b2 to whatever
it was before this can be bizarre to
people who haven't done programming
because it seems like you're you have an
equation that you're solving for
something but in this case the left-hand
side is getting changed it's an
operation on it so if I do that again I
take that same process of turning a into
two to the power of whatever it was
before and then I'll just print it out
in the same line so we can say it turns
into four that turns into 16 that is
going to turn into you can try to make a
prediction here it'll turn into 2 to the
16 which we just saw was 65,536 if I
take one more step which would be a
power tower of height 5 so just 5 2
stacked on top of each other
it totally explodes it's just this
monstrous number which I think it's
awfully kind of Python to even do the
work to find the number for us I'm
impressed with it and if we wanted we
could we could say okay think of that
number as a string what's the length of
that string and it's telling us the
number of digits that are in it so the
number we have there is a 19,000 digit
expression just monstrously huge and if
we were to try one more iteration of
this turning a into 2 to the power of
that 19,000 digit monstrosity you would
not be able to store the information
required for that number anyway that you
were using matter to encode all the
digits of whatever would come out if
that was within the confines of
something like the you know radius of
the earth you would absolutely create a
black hole in any attempt to store that
kind of information so just a power
tower of height 6 and it's it's well
beyond what you can literally physically
convey in any kind of way so you might
ask how quickly does this thing blow up
for other numbers if it's not 2 and one
thing that I'm gonna ask you actually
just in the life pole let's go ahead and
pull it up is to predict what's going to
happen here if instead of two we were
dealing with one point one so if you go
to the link that's in the description
and up on the screen to answer the live
questions along with us we are asked let
B equal one point one so just a little
above one and consider an expression of
the form beat
B to the B to the B this power tower and
its height is n meaning you'll see n
different copies of B how big does n
have to be how many times do have to
repeat this operation before the value
of the expression has more than 10
digits so with 2 we had to get to a
tower of size 5 before that happened it
had jumped from being a 5 digit number
to a 19,000 digit number so how many
times would you have to do it for a
value of B equals 1.1 and I'll give you
a moment to answer that while we listen
to the soothing tones of construction
maybe slowing down and just to
illustrate this process here if we hop
back over to Python and let me just pop
on over here get back into my terminal
let's say I started a at a value of 1
let's just do this in a for loop so for
N and some kind of range like 50 I'm
gonna reassign a what if instead of
doing repeated exponentiation I was just
repeatedly multiplying it by 1 point 1
so just repeated multiplication which
should be exponentiation you can get a
sense of how quickly that grows and if
we take a look here at the first 50
values you know it starts at one point
one it goes to one point two one and at
each stage it's actually growing just by
a little bit by 10% with each jump and
you get classic exponential growth so
with 50 steps it took us up to 117
that's that's exponential growth so you
might wonder what is tetration or growth
what happens if we're repeatedly
exponentiating this thing and before I
answer that let me see what you think
what do you think is going to happen
here if we repeatedly exponentiate this
okay so the correct answer is that it
actually never grows past anything like
that and uh interesting that's the third
place to answer so most of you thought
that then the height that you would need
would be between ten and a hundred doing
it between ten and a hundred times that
would blow you up past ten digits the
second most common answer was thinking
it was between one and ten which would
be very analogous to how two was growing
they're the most common and I'm
wondering how many of those third most
common people have seen
this process before because it's very
weird the idea that repeatedly
multiplying it by itself that'll grow as
much as you want but that somehow doing
what feels like a much more powerful
operation repeatedly exponentiating that
actually stays confined and we can see
this bear out in practice if we hop back
over to our Python we're now what I'm
doing with each iteration and I guess I
should set a to be one again I'm going
to repeatedly turn it into 1 ^ itself
and what we get is a little bit of
initial growth but it quickly slows down
and just within 20 iterations it
actually stays fixed at this value you
can see that this digit isn't changing
and if you think through what's going on
there evidently when a is equal to that
value and you take one point one to the
power of that value so one point one to
the power of this thing that's one point
1 1 1 and 7 yeah don't type it too many
times that actually stays fixed you get
the same value that you had before so
another way that we can phrase this is
to say that the equation 1 point 1 to
the power x equals x something where
when you plug it into the function you
get itself this has a solution
this didn't this didn't hold when we
were doing with 2 if we had 2 to the x
equals x if you try to think through
different answers to this it's a funky
equation to think about but if you just
try out some values like 0 and 1 or
anything in between you'll find there's
actually no answer here
whereas evidently we just saw an answer
in this case and what that means for our
in an iterative process if instead of 2
at the base it was 1 point 1 at the base
you'd have the situation where the
previous value you raise 1.1 to that it
just stays fixed and now this starts
raising a lot of interesting questions
first of all where's the switch what
between what number between 1 and 2 is
the point where it goes from staying
finite to blowing up and blowing up
incredibly quickly at that
remember with 2 it only took us 5
iterations before we had something that
was you know beyond what the computer
could handle and we could play around
with this a little bit but I think
another interesting product of the fact
that this can convert at all is we can
start answering what looked like very
buzz
our questions where I can say imagine I
have an unknown value X and I do not a
power tower of some finite size but of
an infinite size I'm going to keep going
forever in the same way that evidently I
can do with a base of 1.1 can I find a
value of X where this converges for
example to 4 this is the question posed
in the thumbnail of the video and what
we just saw is that we could find a
value that converges to 1 point 1 1 1 7
8 to on and on that's evidently a value
you can converge to and the solution
would be 1 point 1 but how do you go the
other way around how can we actually
solve for the idea that we can find a
value of x that equals 4 and there's a
clever trick here the you might spot and
this comes up in certain problem-solving
kinds of math where you have this
infinite expression and you say there's
some self similarity I can leverage
there's a copy of the entire power tower
inside itself because it's infinite it's
a genuine copy of itself it's not it
doesn't have a height of 1 minus
whatever the previous height was because
the height is infinity and under the
assumption that the whole power tower
equals 4 I could replace that with a 4
and solve X to the 4th equals 4 let's
see what would that be if I take square
roots that's the same as saying x
squared equals 2 so it looks like
interesting x equals square root of 2
gives me a power tower that should
converge to 4 kind of funky the idea
that anything converges at all is sort
of weird but the idea that you know
square root of 2 would go to a clean
value like an integer that's kind of
that's kind of surprising and let me
actually ask you another question where
I'm gonna have you apply the same tactic
that we just did leveraging that self
similarity to solve another one of these
situations where you're looking for a
power tower with an unknown base and
seeing when it equals a pre-specified
value so this time the question is going
to ask us if we give it just a little
moment to pull up here well it's taking
a little moment which is fine oh great
the question asks us using the tactic
just demonstrated what I just did for
for solve the equation X to the X to the
X on and on up to infinity
equals two yeah so I'll give you a
moment to think think that through
the ground Smasher is back man yesterday
when we were doing it we like to I wish
I had the footage to show you maybe I
can try to pull it up on my phone or
something but the things were shaking so
much that just a pile of circuit boards
was actively shaking let me see if I can
find this it's a super funny all right
this appointment this is probably the
worst way to like stream something is to
take an overhead camera shot of a phone
but let me see if this works decently
well so it's trying to get a view of the
construction we move over and there's
the pile of circuit boards it's just
chittering like that and that's what we
have to deal with so hope you enjoy now
on the quiz it looks like just about
everybody is converging around the same
answer and I'm gonna assume you've
landed on the correct answer which is in
fact the square root of 2 which is kind
of a funny thing because if we go when
we do exactly the same logic that we
were doing for solving for for where we
have this infinite power tower and we're
assuming that it equals 2 and we
recognize the self similarity like is
the power tower a copy of it in itself
so that should mean x squared equals 2
that means x equals the square root of 2
well hang on a second this can't be
right because on the one hand this seems
to be suggesting that an infinite power
tower converges to two when the base is
root 2 but on the other hand it
converges to 4 when the vase is root 2
it can't be both we've got a very
deterministic process up here for what
it converges so it's got to be just one
of them if any may be the entire logic
of the situation is false so let's get
empirical let's turn to our programming
to see which one of these it actually
ends up being so I'll hop back over i
will reassign my variable a to be 1 I'm
gonna make my little loop actually let's
import math because I'm gonna need a
square root here so I'm gonna say 4 I
don't know I'll just do 20 at a time I'm
gonna take a turn it into the square
root of 2 square root of 2 to the power
of a print out what it looks like guess
I don't need that semicolon but doesn't
really matter and it looks like for
those first 20 iterations
does kind of slow down as it approaches
to and if I do another 20 iterations
it's definitely slowing down as it gets
to - definitely alright and now it does
something kind of bizarre where it seems
like it lands exactly on two but then it
jumps up 22.000 for which if you think
through what's going on here at some
point it equals two so we're saying a
equals two and then we're taking the
square root of two to the power of that
but square root of two to the power two
by definition should be two so that's
going to be just some simple numerical
error I guess however the math square
root library is implementing square
roots you know there's always going to
be a little bit of numerical error with
floating points so when we square it we
don't exactly get to back that's fine
not a problem but it does seem to
suggest that the correct answer to our
question of what happens when we have a
power tower with root two is that it
equals two or that the sequence of
numbers that this represents approaches
to what's wrong with the other logic
though what's wrong with the logic that
seemed to imply that it should equal
four well to answer that we should do
two things first is to represent this
thing a little bit more visually a
little bit graphically so we can try to
understand what exaggerative process and
then from there understand which values
will converge and which values will blow
up and by answering that we can get back
in the direction of what's wrong with
the logic associated with having this
thing approach four so for that let's
take a look over at our good friend
desmos so pop on over here open up
Chrome not look at that yet that is that
is for later and we will just take a
look at a graph here all right so what I
have is the line y equals x I've got a
function B to the power X and I've said
B to be two so we're just looking at the
graph of two to the X and to think about
the idea of repeatedly applying a
function and kind of taking the output
and then plugging it back into the input
we can draw what's commonly known as a
cobweb diagram and the way this will
work is I have an initial value of 1 as
the input and then the next value is
going to be whatever F of 1
I'm gonna plug in one to the function
and what that means is I move vertically
until I hit the graph and in this case 2
to the 1 is just 2 so I'm gonna hit it
at a y-value of 2 but from there what I
want is the output that I just got that
2 to become an input to the function
but if outputs are represented on the
y-axis and inputs are on the x-axis what
I need is some point where the Y value
is the same as the x value so if I walk
horizontally until the Y value is the
same as the x value I'll get to a point
where 2 is the x value where it can now
think of that 2 as being the input and
to do that I walk until I hit the line y
equals x because once I hit that I'm
looking at 2 comma 2 so I can treat that
2 as an input by moving vertically until
I hit the graph you kind of see how that
works meaning the next point in our
iterative process is going to be 2 to
the power of what we just had which is 2
squared or 4 and then I move over to the
right turning my output into an input
looking for what point on the plane has
an x value that's also equal to 4 then
once I hit that I kind of think of
bouncing off of this line y equals x and
moving vertically until I hit the graph
again and this time it's not until 16
that I hit the graph and then I move to
the right until x also equals 16 and
then from there I have to go quite a
while quite a while moving vertically
but it will happen quite a while and
around 65,000 it intersects the graph
again and then it's going to move to the
right until we get to an x coordinate
that's also 65,000 and from there desmos
just totally gives up on trying to draw
the next vertical line because as we saw
what it would have to get to is a height
where the number describing that height
is a 19,000 digit number so it just it
just gives up on us there but when we
think in terms of these cobweb diagrams
now if I start playing with what is that
base you can see what's going to happen
what is that base the base is the ground
smashing activity at some point the
graphs actually cross each other and so
in particular you know we were looking
at one point one earlier and that
yeah they absolutely cross but even up
to around 1.4 one which is around the
square root of 2
if you look at what happens with this
process we look at the output turn the
output into an input look at the new
output output into an input and bounce
back and forth we're bouncing towards
the value where these graphs intersect
each other okay towards the value where
B of X B to the power X excuse me is
equal to X and in particular if that
base was the square root of 2 and I say
find a solution of square root of 2 to
the power x equals x you know it's not
easy to think about how you solve this
systematically but for this particular
case you would believe me if I told you
that the solution is x equals 2 you can
just plug that in and solve it so if we
look at our graph if B actually let's go
ahead and make it precisely the square
root of 2 rather than just an
approximation here so B is going to be
the square root square root of 2 know of
to the intersection point is exactly at
2 so you see your iterative process
approaching that okay that's kind of
interesting
this also shows us how we're going to
need to think about it if we want to be
if we want to understand where the
switch happens between when things
converge and when things don't converge
because what we want is knowing what
value of B should I go to where things
can escape there is no intersection
point to where things don't escape where
there is an intersection point and by
the way I've left the link to this
particular desmos graphs in the
description so if you want to hop down
there and just play along you're more
than welcome to one thing I should
specify the fact that they intersect
that's actually not enough to ensure
that this cobweb iterative process
necessarily converges it's important
that the graph of our function which in
this case is B to the X intersects at a
slope that's less than 1 and we can
think about why that's true if I turn a
new leaf let's say I wasn't dealing with
exponential functions or curves like
that I was just dealing with any generic
function so look at the line y equals x
and let's say I have some function which
you know it squiggles along and it
intersects it but with a slope greater
than 1 then when we do our iterative
process we'll have some output and we
say let's turn it into an input by
walking horizontally
until we hit y equals x look at the new
output by walking vertically smash smash
smash look at the new input or turn that
output into an input by walking
horizontally until we hit it and then
repeat that process you can see that's
what's happening because it intersected
with a slope greater than one we're
actually walking away from the
intersection point so to make sure that
it's not just a stable point it's not
just a common point between the graphs
but it's stable when you repeat this
process that slope doesn't need to be
less than one I have a whole video about
another perspective on how to think
about this kind of process I think I
gave it I gave it an absurd title like
what they won't teach you in calculus
but if you want to see more examples of
this and fun infinite iterated objects
that's a place that you can turn to now
in our case it is the case that the
slope is less than one so that works
although on the second intersection
point that's actually a slope greater
than one so if I changed the iterative
process where my first value wasn't one
but in this case if I made it four then
my interative process would actually run
away from the intersection point like
you can see and it will indeed blow up
to infinity so that's that's always fun
but I'll change that back to a 1 can
take a look at my little note for being
annoyed that you can't do for loops or
recursion in desmos definitions and you
can see what we need to solve one thing
that's kind of fun here is at one point
4 or 5 which seems just above a point
where they actually intersect you have
this bouncing and bouncing that just it
stays somewhat stable for such a long
time before it eventually blows up and
imagine trying to think about this not
graphically but if you were just playing
around with it numerically so if we had
taken the same process we did before
where a starts out at 1 we're gonna do a
bunch of iterative exponentiating but
we're gonna make it one point four or
five instead and I don't let's give
ourselves like 50 values for this one
the process okay eventually it blows up
it gives us this overflow error but the
processes would be very confusing if you
didn't have any visual for what's going
on starts at one point four five it
grows its
is kind of not stable but it doesn't
seem to be moving that much in the to
point you know the 2.71828 region for
some reason around there it just seems
awfully slow-moving but as it starts to
get a big a little bit bigger into the
three region it stays there for a while
the four region there's two values then
six and the nine and then 39 and then it
just blows up to two million after that
and then from there it's bigger than
what the computer can handle so that
would be deeply confusing except we have
a nice understanding of what's going on
the graphs almost touch but they don't
quite so somewhere between one point
four four and one point four five is
what we're looking for and you might
think of this now in terms of calculus
where what we want is to know when the
tangent of this graph is the same as the
line y equals x wind is the graph B to
the X ly tangent to the line y equals x
and rather than me setting up the
equations that we need to solve for that
I'm gonna have you do the same I'm gonna
have you take a look at this condition
of looking for a value of B well let's
just actually let's just read what the
question asks us more specifically we
want a value of B such that the graph of
y equals B to the X sits tangent to the
graph y equals x which of the following
represents the pair of equations that we
need to solve okay so take a moment to
think about this which of the following
is the pair of equations that we need to
solve
you
while you're thinking about that I'll go
ahead and take a couple questions from
the audience we have to do so
immediately I wondered repeated
tetration is tentation or is that even a
useful idea yeah there's this whole
notation that talks about the idea of
repeating these processes
it's called Knuth arrow notation and you
can kind of have as many as you want
so the way this works is that if I write
something like a arrow B that's the same
thing as a to the power B but then a
with two arrows is the repetition of
that process you know B times and sorry
that's a two arrows and then a B if I
had three arrows three errors and then a
B then what I'm repeating is the process
of doing a double arrow which is really
mind-warping Liebig as you start to
think about it for numbers even numbers
like 2 & 3 the idea of repeating this
process some number of times is just
crazy and you could just keep going with
more and more arrows and if any of you
have not learned about Graham's constant
go over to that number file right now
and see how Graham's constant is defined
because it involves these sort of arrow
operations and it's genuinely crazy and
it's one of the most mind-blowing
moments you'll have in your mathematical
life the first time you see Graham's
constant so would recommend alright so
next we have 41.1 to the power x equals
x Wolfram Alpha yields two real
solutions excellent question one of them
is the one that we converge to the other
is around thirty eight point two nine
awesome what's the deal with that second
solution we can take a look exactly in
the graph that we have so if we take B
and we make it one point one okay it's
what I was talking about how at the
place where it intersects with a slope
greater than one yeah it's a it's a
fixed point for our iterative process
but it's not a stable fixed point so up
here is that 38th value that you were
just referencing and because it
intersect at a slope that's bigger than
one even if you were to seed the process
with a value that's really near there it
would it would run away from that value
so if your
eating the process if you're starting
off at a value of a equals one this is
the intersection point that it'll end up
finding that's an outstanding question
and third are there practical use cases
for such an operation as tetration I've
studied very scientific branch and have
never come across this operator I'm very
curious okay so that that is a spot-on
question so I will talk a little bit
about a role with like chaos and
fractals at the end which is tenuous at
best because it's saying it's related to
other things which themselves are useful
I can't personally think of a place
where like you're out in the wild doing
science and then boom tetration pops up
I can think of a puzzle like a sort of
brain teaser type puzzle where you would
not at all think this operation comes up
but it does which if we have time at the
end I think I might share with you I
would say the motivation for learning
this kind of thing right now is part of
the scene switching chaos there is just
the the process for actually solving the
puzzles that are sitting in front of us
understanding what was up with the
repeated Tower equaling for and
understanding what we're about to find
where is the switching point between
things converging and things not
converging those are problem-solving
tactics that carry over into other
things you might do that involve more
practical iterative processes and
iterative processes absolutely do come
up all throughout science I mean chaos
theory is like the big one there so with
all of that as the answering people's
questions side and I'll think more
through Twitter as we go and probably do
more of that at the end let's see how
you've done on our problem so we're
looking for a system of equations here
and the correct answer which 1777 have
you got I think that's not quite french
revolution territory but american
revolution territory of you we got B to
the x equals x okay so we need them to
intersect and the moreover what we want
is the slope to be the same where they
do intersect and the derivative of B to
the X is itself but scaled by the
natural log of B and we want that slope
to equal 1 because it's got to be the
same as the slope of the graph we're
just looking at and if ever you don't
remember what the derivatives of your
exponential functions are if you do
remember that e to the X is its own
derivative which if there's any one
thing you remember in calculus we
respect to e to the X it should be the e
to the X is its own derivative note that
we can write B as e to the natural log
of B so then all of that to the X so
this is the same as expressing e to the
natural log of B times X we talked about
this I think last lecture so then if you
want to take the derivative of this take
its derivative on the one hand it should
be the derivative of this which by the
chain rule is that constant sitting in
the exponent natural log of B times
itself e to the Ln B times X so what
we're looking at is okay it should be
itself but scaled by something and that
something was the natural log of B now
for our puzzle of understanding when is
it that our graph is going to nicely
light an Junt to y equals x let's solve
this equation this system of equations
actually because we're looking for the
value x where that solution happens we
know that the curve B to the x equals x
at that point and we know that its slope
the natural log of B times itself is
equal to 1 now to solve this the first
thing I might do is note that I can
simplify B to the X as being X so I
would apply that over here and I can
write the natural log of B times X is
equal to 1 ok and what that gives me is
that B is the same as 1 divided by X all
very nice no no it doesn't give me that
it gives me that the natural log of B is
1 over X that is the same statement as
saying e to the 1 over X is equal to B
alright now what does that buy us well
it gives us an expression for B entirely
in terms of X so I can go to this top
part and I can get an equation that has
nothing but X's in it it'll be e to the
1 over X all to the power X I'm just
replacing the B with what we found it to
be and that is supposed to equal X but
on the other hand e to the 1
e to the 1 over X to the power X
simplifies down to simply being e and
what we found is that X is equal to e
and by the way so I was doing like a
sort of a dry run of this lesson last
night where sometimes all I'll put out
like a link to a stream on Twitter
that's an unlisted link and just say
like as soon as a hundred of you hop on
here I'm deleting the tweet and we're
just going to do a dry run and when I
was solving this for some reason I was
just confided for like 10 minutes where
I got to this point I'm like that can't
be right because we're looking for a
value this between one point four four
and one point four five so X can't be e
that's way too big that's like two point
seven one eight so I went back and I was
trying to think through like what have I
done wrong one of the north has gone
wrong here it was it was notably
embarrassing because it took so long
and then I ultimately realized no you
idiot it's not that we're looking for a
value of x that's between one point four
four and one point four five that was
the condition for B for the base of our
exponential when we were playing around
over here X is just wherever they
intersect so it's fine for that to be
around e in fact that looks consistent
that around where this point of tangency
is is e which incidentally is also the
output because this is happening with
the line y equals x so the point of
tangency has coordinates Y comma E
evidently and what does that mean for
the value of B itself once we solve well
we have an exact expression for X we
have an expression for B in terms of X
so this would seem to imply that B is e
to the power of 1 divided by e which is
such a delightfully bizarre answer e to
the power of 1 divided by e and we can
check with our calculator that that
makes some sense so if we hop on over
here and I say hey desmos what is e to
the 1 over e not 1 over 3 1 over e yeah
checks out it is between one point four
four and one point four five which is
exactly what we were looking for for the
point when it goes from not from
converging to exploding very satisfying
I think finding that solution that it's
e to the 1 over e as a challenge puzzle
for you if you want a little bit of
homework today I want you to find a
lower bound on where this converges so
we found the highest value that
this converge but we can also start
playing with values of B that are less
than 1 and if we do that I'll just kind
of get rid of our cobweb here if we do
that there will be some value I guess I
should keep the cob webbing where it's
it's no longer gonna zero in on some
exact value and an instead becomes an
unstable point and the question for you
is when does that happen
wind is it going from go from
approaching the point where the two
graphs intersect to no longer
approaching it because it's unstable and
if you want a hint think about the fact
that the slope in this case it's not a
matter of when it's equal to one it's a
matter of when it's less than negative
one and if you want another hint it
should be an expression that also
involves two E's inside of it so very
fun puzzle if you want to get to it and
that will give you kind of a range of
convergence for what values could we
have as the base in our tetration such
that the power tower actually converges
to something and one thing that's
noteworthy here is that it goes from
converging to a value of e to just
blowing up to infinity it never
converges to values between E and
infinity which maybe runs against
intuition because you would think that
that somehow smoothly blows up that
rather than going oh it converges to one
it converges to two it converges to e
and then discontinuously jumping to
infinity but that is apparently the
behavior and it happens just because the
graphs were once tangent and then that's
where they separate they're kissing and
then they stop kissing and thus answers
for us what's going on in the case of
the power tower with four so if you
think back to the logic where did we
have it great so we if we have our power
tower and I was saying solve for the
value where this equals four well this
assumes that such a value even exists
that this process will ever converge to
before but we just saw that it'll never
converge to be anything that's bigger
than e so in particular the very first
step where we make the substitution
that's leveraging the assumption that a
solution even exists that's invalid and
the reason that it worked for two is
because there does exist a value where
this converges to two so when we make
that initial substitution that's a valid
thing to do and before we even solved it
you could have
seeing that there exists a value air
converges to to by looking at the graphs
what we you would look for even if you
didn't know it was going to be square
root of two we would look for is when
does this intersection point between the
graphs happen at a y-value of two I
guess it's also an x value of 2 because
it's on the line y equals x but what we
care about is that the Y value should be
2 and you would be able to empirically
start seeing that hmm it's somewhere
between one point for one and one point
for two and you could binary search your
way on down even a little bit further so
I think that's delightful that you can
take a look at this absolutely crazy
singing process of a repeated power
tower that it converges at any points at
all which is counterintuitive and that
we can actually make very substantive
statements about when it converges
thinking through iterative processes
like this and that's actually it for
today this is going to be a shorter
lesson that is the end of what I wanted
to say about the power tower puzzle and
leaving you with that little bit of
homework so for the very end here I just
want to take a couple more questions
from Twitter if you ask them with the
hashtag lockdown math they might get
forwarded to me and anything about
tetration and this process is exactly
what we should talk about great so he
says if there's a triangle of exponents
is there a square of tetration what uses
are there for the inverses of tetration
well I mean in in either case we'd be
dealing with 3 3 different variables
there's the idea of what's the what's
the base what's the height and then
what's the output so in either case we
just be having 3 of them the 4 in
tetration like what makes it 4 is not
the fact that there's three relevant
numbers you know the base the exponent
and then whatever the output and then
some new fourth thing it's that in this
process of addition multiplication
exponentiation is kind of the 4th of our
like repeating the process before
next question from ml will you show us
part of the fractal set of complex
numbers X for which the power tower
excavates the X the X converges I'm so
happy that you asked ml yes you might
wonder what happens if instead of our
base equaling 2 or instead of our base
equaling square root of 2 or 1.4 or all
the values we were just looking at what
if you have some complex number
like Z that you're raising to a repeated
power now there's a little bit of nuance
there for what exactly it means to raise
complex values to other complex values
and I think I'm going to talk about that
don't hold me to it I think I'll talk
about that in the next lecture it's it's
very similar to what we see with real
values where you can re-express it in
terms of e and then because we know how
to think about a with complex numbers
you'll be able to do it but if if you if
you are willing to grant the fact that
there does exist a way that you can
extend exponentiation to complex numbers
you could certainly repeat it and when
you repeat it you can start asking about
does this converge and if you asked
about when it converges and if you go
and you write a shader or whatever your
favorite kind of program is to color all
the pixels on the plane based on whether
or not it converges this is what you get
so what you're looking at right now the
axes aren't labeled but the real axis is
running across the middle of the screen
from around negative 4.5 up to I think 3
and then the imaginary axis that's going
from I think like negative 2 I up to 2 I
so this horizontal part of blackness
corresponds to all the values that
converge that we just found where the
upper bound was e to the 1 over E and
the lower bound is what you can find for
homework if you want but the other
values above that diverge and the
coloring tells you how quickly that
diverged so yellow means that it
explodes very quickly blue means that it
explodes less quickly and so on and so
evidently what happens is as you allow
for complex numbers even if they're real
part is greater than e to the 1 over E
that imaginary part can conspire in just
such a way that it makes it converge and
you get this totally intricate pattern
very analogous to the Mandelbrot set
which is also defined in terms of a
certain repeated operation and what this
indicates is there's actually a lot more
intricacy than you might expect
associated with these power towers and
this tetration operation and you get
this a lot where repeated applications
of something can yield chaos and that
chaos is often pictorially reflected in
the fact that a fractal images and it's
kind of like the intricacy of the image
is paralleled in the difficulty of
predicting what what the outputs are
going to be
and just to illustrate the fact that the
outputs can be difficult to predict you
want to know what an unsolved problem is
what no one in the world actually knows
is if you can ever take a power tower
with pies so PI to the power PI to the
power PI to the power PI you do that at
any point is this ever equal to an
integer almost certainly not it would
seem highly unlikely because it's an
irrational number and if you're thinking
of it kind of probabilistically but it's
not probabilistic it's a deterministic
process in fact we don't even know for a
power tower of height for if there's
just four pies here you take PI to the
power pi PI to the power of that PI to
the power of that it ends up being a
monstrous number bigger than we can
compute exactly we don't have a way to
prove whether or not this is an integer
and if you can prove that you know you
will be contributing to the forefront of
math that's the level of what we
actually don't know about these power
towers which i think is kind of
interesting can I share the brainteaser
where the arrow operator shows up yeah
fantastic let me I can draw it out for
you I think this came from an IMO this
is something that potion law was sharing
with me at one point and I'm sure he has
a talk about it somewhere that will be
more illustrative than what I can talk
about on the fly here but the way this
will work is that we have six different
cups and each cup is going to start out
with a single coin in it okay and you
have two different operations available
to you one of those operations is that
you can remove the coin from one cup
okay so we'll remove it from one cup
within two more coins will drop into the
cup to its right okay so there's a
there's a certain directionality to this
now two more will drop into the one to
its right so you could imagine from here
we could then eliminate all three coins
and then there would be six that just
magically drop in five six magically
drop into the next cup beside it and if
that was the only ability that you had
kind of a warm-up teaser is to
understand that the maximum number of
coins you can have ends up being 63 if
you just sort of keep doing this process
of taking out
coins doubling it but shifted one over
you can get up to 63 now if I introduce
the second magical operation which is
that I can eliminate one of the coins in
a cup and instead of magically dropping
two into the next one I swap the two
that are sitting right after it I swap
their positions that's the second power
that you have which seems less magical
because it doesn't require bringing
about coins from the ether I think the
way that this was originally framed is
is the maximum amount of money that you
can have after doing this process bigger
or smaller than two thousand ten to the
power two thousand ten to the power two
thousand ten that was the question
when you have these two abilities and
you start with six cups that each have
one coin in them will it be bigger than
the maximum amount of money that you can
get if you're clever enough the bigger
or smaller than that power tower of
height three and it's just again kind of
absurd that that second operation would
get you anywhere near that level of
number because this is I mean this is
just so huge it's way bigger than
anything you'll find in physics unless
you're doing statistical mechanics or
something like that so yeah excellent
question and with that unless there's
anything more that people want to ask
and which also ends up getting forwarded
to me I think I'm going to go ahead and
call it a day on this one and thank you
for joining I think I will ultimately
probably have ten episodes in this
lockdown series is what I'm thinking at
the moment so if you want to join for
the next two those will be the last two
oh great we have another question when
you solved X to the X to the X on a non
equals two and got x squared equals two
you ignored the negative square root of
two awesome yeah a solution two x
squared equals two can I explain why ah
that yeah that's absolutely outstanding
let's so if we think about this
graphically again where that helps us be
a little bit more concrete when it comes
to what's going on with the iterative
process when I said be equal to around
1.4 1 yeah it seems like nothing's
really happening around the negative
square root of 2 okay
so let's try to understand
why that's happening there's not even
necessarily a an intersection at that
point so the reason we were taking
square roots of 2 when we were looking
at our power tower operations if we
remind ourselves we had the assumption
that there even exists in answer this
whole thing no not with an X at the top
it just goes up to infinity equals 2 we
saw the reflection of itself x squared
equals 2 let's think about what this
would mean what do we mean to have a
negative square root here well I guess
what you'd be assuming is that you
you're taking negative powers now that I
think about it if we set X equal to the
negative square root of 2 then you'd be
raising it in the next process you would
take negative square root of 2 you would
raise it to a negative power ok so
raising to a negative power we're
already in the realm of thinking about
negative square root of 2 to the 1 over
now negative 1 over square root of 2 to
the square root of 2 mm why doesn't that
end up popping up in the intersection or
anything like that actually the more I
think about it there might be a very
obvious answer to what's going on that
I'm missing other than I mean we can
talk about we can talk about the fact
that negative numbers don't sit in the
range of convergence like if you solve
the homework problem the assumption that
there exists an X that's negative they
converges like this would be false
because you'll find that the the bound
ends up I think it ends up being a to
the negative e so in the same way that
it failed our logic failed in the case
of for our logic fails if we just plug
in square root of negative 2 I'm kind of
curious if that breaks down numerically
so if we do try this over in our Python
where let's again set equal to 1 let's
find our for loop where now we're going
to do the negative square root of 2 and
repeat the process yeah what do we get
we do get a stable point
testing it's negative square root of 2
you look like you're a very stable point
you're not a stable point that's equal
to 2 at all what is that number what's
going on there you know what I I'm not
entirely positive now that now I have it
now I have a decision to make it do I
try to think about what exactly is going
on on screen live rather than just
calling it into the stream or do I do I
think about it and then put like pin
that to a comment at the end let's see
what's going on with our logic exactly
we're saying assume that they're equals
a value that converges to two if there
does it's going to satisfy this property
I mean cuz I guess what you can say is
it's like x equals plus or minus square
root of two you try them both one of
them equals one of them doesn't end of
story
I mean this happens a lot when you're
doing something algebraic you have a
manipulation like this you have multiple
possibilities but you just kind of plug
them in to check and one of them just
doesn't work but that's always very
unsatisfying because what you want is
some sort of answer to why it looked
like it was going to work but didn't so
in the case of a power tower that equals
4 you could very clearly see why it
didn't the assumption that it even
converged was false and I guess in this
case our assumption would be if we had
negative root 2 if we have a negative
value that what's sitting up here is
still equal to 2 hmm I don't know we
could we saw that it doesn't we can say
when you're when you're doing this you
try them both and if one of them doesn't
that's all it is but that just doesn't
feel satisfying to me so I'll think
about that a little bit if anyone has
deeper thoughts um share them in the
comments of course I would love to hear
what you have to say it's sort of a like
what's going on with the square root of
negative 2 what does it converge to and
why does it have any relation to this
process which as we already saw is a
faulty line of reasoning and like a
little bit shaky to just replace what's
inside your infinite power tower with
the assumptions you've already made
yeah I'll think on that excellent
question and I think that's a great
place to end it all so I couldn't help
but notice the the Twitter handle for
who is asking that because this is
someone who's created these super
beautiful notes for all of the lock down
series so far which I've been throwing
in the video descriptions just because
I'm like yeah this is boy do I wish my
handwriting looked anything like that so
if anyone wants to check them out now
she's done she's done a beautiful job
and with that I will actually call it an
end to today's lesson I'll see you at
Friday at the same time for our
second-to-last in the lockdown math
series
[Music]
you
[Music]